if you're excited about GTA heists as
much as the rest of us you're going to
want to make sure you're ready that
means getting to the required level of
12 as soon as possible so I put together
a short list do's and don'ts to make
sure you level up quickly as a patch 2.0
for 360 and ps3 or patch 1.06 for Xbox
one and ps4 now these aren't cheats or
tricks that are just going to be patched
in a week this is a regular overview of
things you should just know when you're
looking to get levels join a crew
immediately there are tons of benefits
to being in a crew with lots of people
and the most important one is that you
get RP for playing with friends and crew
members you get a 20% bonus just for
completing a mission with a crew member
plus you get another 10% RP bonus if
they're your friend so get your friends
all on the same crew and complete
missions to increase your rank join
servers that have at least six people in
them you don't want to be anywhere alone
the more people in your server the
higher chance you'll have to run into
player bounties armored cars loot drops
and other free mode events you also get
small pockets of RP for doing things
with other people like riding in a car
and flying it's not a lot but it's
pretty much free RP so I can't stress it
enough join a crew if you don't know any
crews you can join GameSpot's crew we
have a stupid t-shirt you can wear but
more importantly we'll help you level up
use your newly acquired crew members and
friends and play contact missions use
quick jobs on your phone host and make
sure to click auto invite that'll invite
anyone currently in your crew to play
with you and it will help fill your game
up be patient and wait for about four
people to players on the same crew next
you 10% more cash three players gets you
20% and four players tops it out at 30%
that cash is going to come in handy in
your early levels so that you can buy
guns and cars so don't neglect it money
is valuable to put the difficulty up too
hard it'll earn you a 50% RP bonus plus
a cash bonus for anyone else in the
mission finally you can change the
targeting mode to free aim which will
give you an extra 25 % RP bonus for all
participants but be warned it makes it
pretty hard when the mission is over
don't forget to vote you get 50 RP for
each vote not much but over time that
[ __ ] adds up when your mission is over
try picking more missions they typically
have a larger payout they're the ones
with the stars
be on the lookout for higher ranked
contact mission invites this is again
where your crew and your friends come in
a low-level player can't play the higher
ranked missions by themselves if your
friend invites you it's all good and you
get that high RP that comes with it for
instance contact missions from Giraud
will not only typically result in more
RP and cash rewards but they're more
diverse and generally more fun take your
time in the missions most people want to
rush through and hurry to get the reward
but there's a duration multiplier that
gives you more payout for the longer
you're in the missions so you're getting
more money for each minute you're
actively trying to complete the
objective it maxes out after 16 minutes
but most missions don't take that long
so it's not really a problem you get RP
bonuses for headshots plus NPCs are down
for good you also get Awards with RP for
the first deaths with any particular
weapon so try out lots of different
weapons and always purchase the gear you
should avoid the open world and the
grind at first there are some highest
level players in that open world and
they will SWAT you like a casual fly so
stick to the missions if you're just
hanging out in the open world you could
rob a store it gives you about 150 RP
and a thousand bucks and for every
wanted star you lose you gain 100 RP if
you can get there you get 50 RP for each
minute you last with 5 stars but it's
not really as lucrative as it sounds if
you're looking at RP per minute it's
still best to do missions don't be
tricked into the car import requests
they take a long time and if your car
gets banged up you pay for it it comes
out of your pocket it can take 10
minutes to gain an easily 300 RP that's
only 30 RP a minute if you're in the
open world you could consider impromptu
short races that'll give you about 300
RP just for winning it only takes 30
seconds but you'll always find that the
best meet is in the missions with
higher-level friends and crew members so
watch for the invites and check the
levels of the missions landing strip got
me over 3,100 RP and over 18,000 in just
over 10 minutes
stick up the stick-up crew got me over
3200 RP and 17,000 cash in under 8
minutes and as you level up you'll
unlock your own missions that are pretty
good messed up only requires a level
seven so be on the lookout for that one
in five minutes you can get about 1,500
RP and over $8,000 cash you should pay
attention to the RP per minute but don't
get bogged down on time it's also
important to stop and remember that
you're playing a ridiculously beautiful
game in an incredibly immersive world
there's more than enough here to keep
you entertained for a long time so make
some friends and gain some levels while
having fun there's a lot more to get
into here but this is a good start we'll
probably be making another video for
quickly leveling once you get to 50 so
keep going and if you have any quick
tips and tricks put them in the comments
below see you in Los Santos simple it
should be the easiest money you'll ever
make
you